je vous posais la question qui tue
maintenant peggy bouchet est ce qu'on
peut faire la lumière de la question qui
tue sexuellement ça se passe et comment
sur ce bateau c'est difficile un
sérieusement
ça vous a manqué non je crois que quand
on fait beaucoup d'efforts comme ça
comme ça et puis non on n'y pense pas
trop
non mais c'est pas une partie de
rigolade corsa verticale arabe
donc c'est c'est cas de le dire c'est de
la galère tous les jours c'est des peurs
sais les souffrances est bon tout ça n'a
pas le temps passer au reste aux médias
ça vous fait appeler mais bon alors
regardez moi la question je vous vois
pas mais moi je vois alors que jusqu
alors le pognon là il est au sérieux
alors aujourd'hui il est dans une banque
en suisse gardé par la justice suisse
j'ai dit ok on rallume
est-ce que
vous aviez eu à choisir donc entre d'une
part vivre en arabie saoudite
cloîtré avec vos enfants ou quitter
l'arabie saoudite et vivre sans vos
enfants est-ce que des fois vous vous
dites pas j'aurais mieux fait de rester
en arabie saoudite parce que je serai
toujours avec mes enfants je me dis ça
tous les matins je vous dis ça tous les
matins et tous les matins quand je parle
à mes enfants je leur demande de me
pardonner d'avoir décidé de partir parce
que je ne pouvais plus être une bonne
mère où je pensais qu'à la fin je vais
devenir une mère folle et mais je sais
aujourd'hui ma force de résistance était
telle que j'aurais pu rester et
d'ailleurs mon fils aîné mené jusqu'à
présent maman tu es parti trop tôt
[Musique]
bienvenue à l'iss non non est-ce que
vous avez jamais regretté cette
opération jamais jamais
[Musique]
non non je suis très heureuse et pour
rien au monde je me souviens quand je
suis rentrée à la clinique
je me suis dit mais tu étais sûr qu
est-ce que c'est en train de faire parce
qu'il fallait vraiment faire confiance
c'est très si au médecin parce que le
fait que je fasse un métier public et
bon c'était c'était assez dangereux
quand même et j'ai eu qu'on vous j'ai la
foi comme je lé souvent dans ma vie et
je me suis dit j'y vais je pense que
c'est quelque chose de bien pour moi
graviora lui
alors répondez moi
quelle époque mon père était donc
ministre de la jeunesse et des sports et
dans le cadre donc de sens de son action
il devait venir sur le campus de
nanterre où moi j'étais étudiante pour
inaugurer et la piscine de nanterre et
et à l'époque donc il y avait comme une
sorte d'effervescence qui commençait sur
le campus c'était en janvier et les
événements à l'espace et en mai et donc
à l'époque c'était pas plus d'une
quarantaine à peu près d'étudiants mais
qui commence est quand même à faire un
peu de grabuge et à leur tête il y avait
un homme un garçon donc qui s'appelait
daniel cohn bendit et lorsque mon père
est arrivé pour inaugurer la trentaine
d'étudiants l'attendait et à ce moment
là ils ont commencé à dire à mon père
qu'est ce que vous faites vous pour les
problèmes sexuels des jeunes étudiants
et mon père leur a répondu je viens
inaugurait des piscines et puis toi qui
m'a posé la question si tu as un
problème sexuel plonge donc la tête la
première tu verras ça résout déjà pas
mal de jeunes
et puis à l'époque donc comme mon père
était ministre il était suivi par
pléthore de personnes dont un préfet de
police et le préfet de police trouvant
que ce jeune homme s'était mal adressée
à mon père à demander comme ils étaient
de nationalité étrangère qu'il soit
expulsé et mon père a dit à ce moment là
non je suis désolé si on doit expulser
quelqu'un on excuse pour le des raisons
valables mais c'est tout de même pas
parce qu'il m'a posé cette question là
qu'il doit être expulsés du territoire
français
ce qui me paraît d'ailleurs très normal
est censé comme réponse et puis les
événements sont arrivés de 68 et là vous
savez les gens commencent à perdre la
boule on savait plus très bien où on en
était surtout due à des journaux
notamment un journal qui heureusement
n'existe plus aujourd'hui et qui étaient
orduriers et qui a commencé à dire
il semble que il paraît que on croit que
mais qui n'affirme est jamais ce garçon
qui s'appelle cohn bendit n'a pas été
expulsé de france parce qu'il a été
protégé par le ministre parce que il
avait il a fait rester là or je n'ai
jamais rencontré cohn bendit qu'il a
d'ailleurs écrit lui-même dans un de ces
dans un bouquin je crois et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui si je le vois dans la rue
eh bien moi je le reconnaîtrai parce que
je sais la tête il a je le vois des
émissions de télé à etc
mais lui et je crois incapable de dire
quelle est la couleur de mes yeux et je
finis d'ailleurs paru regretter parce
que je me dis que tant qu'à faire quand
vous prêtez ac est une histoire autant
connaître vraiment la personne avec
laquelle justement voudrait bien on
rallume la lumière merci
laurent gerra d'un sérieux vous
m'arriverait jamais non je pensais pas
non à oui c'est un principe parce que sa
femme c'est pas pratique c'est ça ça
représente rien pour moi alors on dit
oui mais pour faire plaisir à la femme
qu'on aime simatic vous le demande même
et je lui ferais plaisir mais je ne
ferai pas plaisir à moi donc un horaire
qui sera lésé dans les deux donc ce que
j l'amour c'est regarder la télévision
dans le même sens donc c'est définitif
bah ouais je crois je crois ouais bon on
rallume serbe ses tresses et arrive
alors et ça n'a fait faucher pas ça ne
fait pas cela rend pas triste mathilde
je chie m'enfin bon elle me connaît
mathilde seigner
bien elle n'est pas là je sais qu'il
n'est pas l'accord
jamais en fait vous êtes géré assez
d'origine piémontaise en fait
transfrontalier transalpin dix ans et on
comprend mieux votre personnage quand on
sait ça en fait parce que vous avez un
côté commedia dell arte est d'ailleurs
votre premier rôle à lyon c'était
damistes dans une pièce en général je
tiens ma les deux comédies quoi oui
c'était celle tartuffe way et donc que
vous avez ce côté commedia dell'arte de
trouver comme sadeghi milk des phrases
clés en fait en business et ça en fait
le mal qui mixe et installe toujours un
personnage
ouais c'est ça le sale situe
immédiatement donc c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours eu ce taré mais si ça
maintenant maintenant j'ai compris ça je
vous comprends et je commence à en
croire le personnel
gilbert collard quoi est ce que quand
vous dites gilbert collard qu'on vous
dit
quand vous dites gilbert collard quand
vous dites quoi plus rien on ne m'aime
pas et je le sais est ce que finalement
votre quand même dans la vie ça serait
pas d'être aimée tout simplement je
crois que le problème de tous les êtres
humains c'est de n'être pas assez aimée
oui oui oui je le confesse volontiers
oui
donc c'est pour ça vous êtes comme ça
peut-être peut-être vous êtes sincère là
tout à fait dit la vérité là on rallume
cergy
patrick poivre d'arvor eux
que répondez vous à ceux qui disent qu à
votre place
aux usa le présentateur du journal
télévisé aurait déjà démissionné
moi j'ai démissionné j'ai démissionné
mes patrons n'ont pas voulu que je parte
mais j'ai proposé ma démission
j'ai payé ma rédemption je pense l'avoir
connu dans les deux affaires auxquelles
vous est fait allusion
et puis voilà et je pense que les gens
qu'on payait bas ils ont le droit à une
nouvelle chance et donc ça me paraît pas
absurde très cher à l'ubs merci alors
c'est la question qui tue francis huster
est pas la question qui fâche comme
disent certains copieurs c'est au sujet
des j'adore la vie christiane à vous a
dit quoi franchement elle vous aviez
quand elle a vu le spectacle
elle vous a dit quoi j'étais
complètement con elle avait vu un
festival c'est l'avait trouvé ça
formidable comme un crétin j'ai fait
trois erreurs le soir de la générale il
y avait un micro avec une réverbération
dans la sage d'épouvantables on a
l'impression que je parlais devant
derrière
en plus on m'avait dit de me méfier de
tous les sketches de paysans j'en ai 3
ou 4 3 est pas mal mais jouer tactique
bio et donc ça alors voilà au bout de
deux ans on en a marre et puis la
troisième chose c'est qu'effectivement
j'aurais peut-être dû commencer la
trilogie avec la peste ou du textile a
trouvé que j'avais des couilles
d'arrêter elle n'était pas très chaude
pour le spectacle non non non elle le
trouvait travail c'était de la folie
très bien trop risqué donc elle vous
aime on rallume
cristiana reali et francis huster bien
racontée est un succès avec la chatte
sur un toit brûlant énorme distribution
dans la tombe d'ailleurs vous pouvez lui
dire un questionnaire on vous attend il
paraît qu'elle a un petit peu peur de
moi alors je vous le dit christiana chez
un mec vachement sympa ivana trump
questions importantes si demain matin
donald trump revenez vers vous et vous
proposer de reprendre la vie de famille
avec vos enfants
il y en oublie tout on se remet ensemble
tous et on reprend une vie normale tu me
pardonnes excuse moi est ce que vous
seriez d'accord est ce que vous lui
diriez oui ou non à ce stade je dirais
non
j'en suis vraiment convaincu d'abord
parce que je suis amoureuse d'un autre
homme et puis y'a tellement de mal qui a
été fait bon bien sûr je suis remonté et
maintenant les enfants nous réussir
un stade de baie paisible et moi je veux
continuer avec ma vie et puis donald a
des intérêts quitte son différent moi
j'ai des intérêts différents je passe
beaucoup de temps en europe je jouais de
ma vie je fais des choses différentes et
lui il continue à travailler travailler
travailler vont appliquer ces milliards
et c'est pas fait pour moi ce n'est plus
fait pour nos groupes aucun espoir on a
les mains non juifs même si votre père
est juif et votre mère l'est pas en tant
que juive canton portant un patronyme
juifs vous retrouver en occident ça les
a jamais embêté et moi sincèrement de
l'aider sa durée de trois ans je n'ai
jamais ressenti le moindre sentiment de
ce genre dans un moment politique est
d'ailleurs aucun des membres 17 heures
l'association d'étudiants qui ont fait
de la politique que par la suite ne sait
par exemple retrouver au front national
vous avez cité des noms tout à l'heure
il y en a d'autres
ils sont tous dans des formations
politiques de la droite républicaine ou
qu'un est allé au front national et moi
je n'ai jamais à cette époque ressenti
le moindre racisme
d'abord c'était pas du tout le sujet à
l'époque c'était effectivement le
communisme la guerre du vietnam les
événements de mai 68
donc ce n'était pas du tout le sujet et
je n'ai jamais ressenti cela d'ailleurs
si je l'avais ressenti évidemment
j'aurais pas pu y rester
non non c'est pas ça c'était pas ça du
tout accident c'est vraiment un
mouvement d'étudiants qui se défendent
est dans un univers pas très simple ok
j'ai vu c'est terrible
alors la main qu est-ce que en vous
voyant être devenu le chantre du capital
est ce que vous croyez pas que votre
père vous savez c'est un ancien
communiste
ils ont fait aussi beaucoup de chemin
alors j'ai poursuivi le chemin qu'il
avait entamée si je puis dire j'étais
allé très loin parce que quand même lui
peut être communiste et avoir été déçu
par par le stalinisme il peut avoir été
des hommes par par budapest il peut
avoir été déçu par beaucoup de choses
comme ça
mais malgré tout il est quand même là un
idéal au départ près des halles
communiste le fait que son fils soit
devenu le chantre du nouveau capitalisme
s'allonge pas de dormir non mais vous
voyez qu'en dit libéral de gauche c'est
assez utile parce que j'espère que lui
comprend gauche et que les gens avec
lesquels je travaille comprennent
libéral
ouais très bien on rallume debré vous
savez que jacques chirac eux est malade
c'est pour ça qu'il a grossi
dernièrement c'est pour ça qu'après les
vacances tout le monde l'a trouvé un
pont ce un petit peu enflée du visage
vous apprenez donc les cancéreux qui
prend de la cortisone comme le président
pompidou que ce traitement occasionne un
comportement encore pire que celui qu'il
a en ce moment non vous faites quoi
tient à rien je voterai pas pour lui la
prochaine fois mais vous le dit pas mais
non on rallume bahreïn maintenant
sérieusement est-ce que vous avez un
mime et niekro preuve que jean-pierre
mairie aurait pu être assassiné
ou est ce que c'est une vous dites il
aurait pu être assassiné puisque vous
avez un début
de quelque chose vous savez on n'a pas
besoin de forcément d'une preuve là la
preuve la reine de la preuve c'est
l'aveu de la propre personne
mais on a des indices graves et
concordants et vous savez et d'envié le
système judiciaire français par exemple
les assises il n'y a pas besoin de
preuve il suffit que les gens sont
convaincus
il suffit que les personnes qui sont
derrière qui vont juger
il suffit qu'ils assez d'éléments pour
qu'ils soient convaincus est qu'il donne
vingt ans de prison à la personne qui
est qu'ils ont à juger au rhume
jean claude gayssot donc excusé pas le
sentiment que vous vivez une aventure
personnelle vivez votre compte de fait
est que finalement vous avez pu oublier
que j'étais ouvrier que je l'étais de
l'autre côté
non je n'ai rien oublié et
et je peux vous dire que quand on a été
non seulement pauvre comme je l'étais
mais un militant es militant pour la
justice un militant un contre les
privilèges quels qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs pas simplement de la fortune
mais aussi du pouvoir et du savoir
eh bien ça s'oublie pas et quand ils
vous arrivent cet aspect exceptionnel de
vous retrouver ministre à ce moment là
votre petite échelle de continuer à ne
pas oublier ce que vous avez été ce que
sont des millions 10 millions dont merci
on rallume merci beaucoup
henri d'orléans croyez-vous après avoir
entendu tout ça que la famille d'orléans
puisse encore régné sur la france
ça ne dépend que des français on rallume
alors jorian nous allume faire de la
radio vous avez voulu faire de la télé
vous avez voulu réaliser des films j'ai
voulu faire des affaires mais une
société de tournage de films français
aux états unis et team america en france
vous avez voulu faire de la décoration
d'hôtel mais si vous aviez choisi d'être
que acteurs pensez pas qu'aujourd'hui
vous soyez un des premiers acteurs du
monde seulement acteur parce que c'est
pas moi qui ai choisi d'être acteur
c'était pas moi c'était pas mon truc moi
je suis
je voulais faire partie du spectacle et
surtout je voulais écrire des choses
quand on défend me demande on me dit
mais qu'est ce que vous regrettez le
plus je dire je regrette simplement que
pendant des années on mais on ne met pas
demandé d'écrire des dialogues parce que
j'étais persuadé que je serai un bon
dialoguiste michel audiard c'est sûr et
il garde le disait l'égalité tu devrais
quand des diarrhées mais les gens
voulaient pas mais je dis ça sans
aigreur puisque j'ai fait d'autres
choses plus lucratives mais pour moi
acteurs c'est pas le truc évidemment qui
me passionne le plus
et si c'était à refaire vous referiez la
même chose et je t'ai suspect refaire je
referais la même chose dans les grandes
lignes c'est dire que je met par exemple
je ferai beaucoup plus de choses dans la
décoration ou beaucoup plus de choses en
urban à huy où beaucoup plus de choses
dans des choses comme ça doit être dans
dix ans la musique trop dans la musique
c'est bien tu crois c'est vrai j'aurais
adoré travailler avec avec des
urbanistes aimé partie du projet
brasilia ouais tout ce facteur qua non
pas tous aux facteurs mais on est
toujours acteur de quelque chose dans
une société qui nous entoure
on a les mains
alors ne montebourg est-ce que vous
pensez pas que vous seriez quand même
plus crédible si vous vous occupiez
parallèlement d affaire de la mnef et
pas seulement de chirac mais aussi de
monsieur le guen de monsieur cambadélis
de monsieur dominique strauss kahn je
vais vous dire que le parti socialiste
en est occupé ouais et à empêcher toute
candidature de cela et que par ailleurs
le parti socialiste avait demandé à
l'époque le départ un nombre de ceux qui
étaient mis en difficulté donc je suis
heureux de voir que mon parti faites un
effort dans ce stress penser que le
parti socialiste n'a pas besoin d'arnaud
montebourg mais seulement le rpr qui en
a besoin
ça je ne sais pas qui est une question
différente et compliqué mais on aura une
main
jean marie messier questions simples
quoi que vous disiez est ce que vous
pensez sérieusement qu alain de greef
est encore l'homme de la situation en
tant que directeur des programmes de
canal plus ce que je crois c'est que
alain de greef et un homme de programme
remarquable par seulement derrière pour
les programmes de canal+ mais pour
l'ensemble des chaînes thématiques et
des différentes offres de canal et c'est
l'autre ambition le c'est pas mon
ambition pour lui c'est le choix qu'il
doit faire et un truc qui est bien c'est
que on entend beaucoup de critiques sur
npa en disant mais c'est dépassé ça a
changé et c'est qu'il faut d'abord moi
je suis pas nostalgique
gildas de caunes c'était génial dujon
c'est pas mal du tout et il ya un truc
qui est simple canal ça toujours été à
la pointe de l'innovation
on le doit de greffe et de greffe encore
énormément de choses à porter canal n'y
pas de doute là dessus
[Musique]
jean glavany
c'est très simple on se souvient n'en
profite pas à laurent parce qu'il fait
nuit on se souvient du nuage de
tchernobyl qui s'était arrêté à la
frontière franco allemande
alors concernant la sphère de la vache
folle est ce qu aurait des choses qu'on
ne sait pas nous français oui mais c'est
pas parce que vous voulez cacher on le
sait pas parce que vous le savez pas non
plus mais c'est pas si je laissais pas
non plus parce que l'énergie qui ne le
savent pas non plus il n'ya pas des
choses que vous savez aujourd'hui je
vois tu rien des choses gran on dit vaut
mieux pas le dire aux gens parce que non
ça va être la psychose nationale rien
c'est sûr certains
donc vous dites y'a rien français que
vous ne sachiez pas sur cette affaire
non vraiment franchement rien très bien
en radio
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors eric cantona cette décision de pas
vous faire jouer en équipe de france en
98 qui est pas été du tout comprise par
les par les français parce que tout le
monde attendait évidemment vous soyez
dans l'équipe de france est-ce que vous
en voulez aimé jacquet est ce que vous
avez de la haine parce que finalement
votre rêve s'est envolé ce jour là non à
un moment donné j'ai eu de la haine bien
sûr j'aime ou pas de la haine mais bon
oui j'aurais préféré jouer mais
aujourd'hui non je suis innocent j'ai
plus du tournage arrive et puis ce qui
s'est passé c'est très bien peut-être
que si j'avais joué ce n'est pas passé
comme ça peut-être que si j'avais joué
serait passé comme ça ou peut-être que
ça ne sera jamais et puis c'est bien que
ça se soit passé comme ça je vous ai pas
le sentiment d'être orphelin de cette
victoire d'une certaine façon j'ai vécu
les des trucs extraordinaires des
grandes des grandes joies et des grandes
déceptions et ça fait partie des grandes
déceptions et ça fait partie de la vie
ça fait partie des choses qui nous font
avancer
on allume donc ce que vous dites
monseigneur di falco ce soir c'est que
un catholique peut très bien utiliser un
préservatif et tout le monde puisque des
préservatifs c'est pas condamnée par le
vatican
à partir du moment vous ne parvenez pas
à vivre l'idéal de fidélité par exemple
et que vous avez des relations sexuelles
on peut pas prendre le risque d'être
soit criminel soit suicidaire il faut
utiliser le préservatif ce qu'on
attendait christian de bon sens non mais
attendez ça c'est la position de
monseigneur di falco qui est à passer la
position où la position du pape c'est la
position explique les de façon claire de
l'église on rallume donc hervé bourges
pour quelles raisons
pour quelle raison le csa a accordé à
tf1 qui est déjà riche à milliards
deux minutes de plus de pub par heure
pour quelles raisons
puis écouter ils adhèrent la décision
qui a été prise à l'époque est une
décision juridique parce que c'était le
droit commun c'est tout alors qu'elles
vont faire ce cadeau un tel cadeau c'est
vous qui le dites moi j'ai rien d'autre
à quand un commercial deux minutes de
plus de pub c'est un cadeau qu'on lui
fait comme accor
moi j'ai rien d'autre à ajouter ben on
rallume 6 par rapport aux alors je vous
pose est maintenant une dernière
question est ce que vous éteignez la
lumière
question simple gilles ménage question
très simple vous êtes un au service de
l'état avait fait des narvals été dans
les cabinets préfectoraux est ce que
finalement maintenant avec le recul
puisque publier des livres pour en
parler
est ce que vous regrettez pas excusé pas
un peu honte d'avoir fait tout ça
finalement nombre je pense déjà on non
je vais vous dire pourquoi parce que
d'abord je qualifie pas comme vous les
qualifiés est ce que je peux dire c'est
qu'à chaque fois qu'une décision a été
prise
j'ai toujours fait un papier écrit j'ai
toujours demandé d instruction je suis
instructions je ne pense vraiment pas
avoir franchi la ligne jaune
je veux pas je veux pas vous chargez
m'enfin papon aussi dit moi je ne
faisait qu'obéir aux ordres
quand on est fonctionnaire hors d europe
mais quand on est fonctionnaire jeudi à
dubaï aux arbres il bien bonjour cas des
fois il faut savoir désobéir
c'est ce que tout le monde a dit à
papandréou non vous auriez dû désormais
on n'était pas du tout dans cette
configuration là je vous la situation
était moins grave
bon lorsque ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est le fond de ma réponse un
fonctionnaire si vous voulez ne peut pas
prendre l'initiative en tout cas moi
c'est ma philosophie
sans être totalement en harmonie avec le
pouvoir politique
or il se trouve que dans son pays dans
ce pays à taden politique parce que ça
les arrange parce qu'ils ont des soucis
de carrière sont parfois amnésique
parfois renégats et ça devient un peu
facile de 10
ben voilà nous on n'était pas au courant
on savait pas de taper le lampiste alors
vous dites non moi j'ai pas
après tout je trouve que j'ai eu
beaucoup de satisfactions à faire ce
métier il ya depuis quelques années
c'est vrai beaucoup d'inconvénients
je pense que dans la vie il faut savoir
accepter les inconvénients c'est
davantage bien à lui merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]